[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
véritable star du 7e art Sophie Marceau
émotion prendre sa plume et vient de
sortir un recueil de poèmes consacré au
désir féminin en pleine promo de son
ouvrage l'actrice a accordé une
interview au journal Libération où elle
s'est confiée sur ses propres désirs si
en matière d'amour chacun ses propres
préférences la femme de 56 ans a de son
côté révélé être sapiosexuel en clair la
beauté d'un homme l’intéresse peu elle
est attirée par l'intelligence et par le
savoir une déclaration étonnante qui a
surpris de nombreux fans de l'actrice et
vous êtes-vous plutôt attiré par le
cerveau par le physique
[Musique]
il m'a appelé Sophie je comprends pas
l'intelligence
rend sexy ça veut dire que peut-être le
physique ne suis pas non plus je
comprends pas ce que tu dis tu veux dire
Sophie
sexuelle qu'est-ce qu'elle a oh non pas
avec lui
il adore
[Rires]
c'est bien pour Bernard
ça tu la verras même pas
tu nous fais chier donc elle aime bien
et toi c'est pareil moi je le faisais
quoi
donc bien sûr en même temps elle dit
qu'elle aime les hommes charismatiques
intelligents et instruit je connais peu
de femmes qui disent qu'ils aiment les
hommes
en même temps c'est pas non plus une
grande révélation
elle m'a résumé très bien
en plus moi j'ai une Walker pour je fais
Marsault donc
c'est la seule femme ou je serai
pardonné par ma femme vous savez
jamais malheureusement les couples vous
savez on se dit que
c'est alors aucun risque
elle m'a dit que je ressemblais à la
fois
[Applaudissements]
tu prends tes affaires et tu dégages
pas du tout aucune carte moi
mais même si c'est la voiture
c'est hypothétique
je pourrais pas vous citer une star
internationale
personne
Josiane Mimoun
non franchement personne n'a rien
personne toi Sophie Marceau je te jure
il a la classe non mais c'est pas ça
Christophe Lambert le kiné
c'est ce qu'elle dit c'est assez
fréquent chez les femmes mais chez les
hommes l'inverse c'est pas vrai c'est à
dire que les femmes qui sont des
sublimes femmes au bras d'hommes qui
sont intelligents mais pas forcément
très beau il y en a beaucoup l'inverse
c'est pas forcément d'accord
[Rires]